Trisha Yearwood hello young living
legends nice I like that no one ever
says the young legend I'll take it
no no not alleged yet but I'm having a
great time you are having a great time
you can hear it on the new album let's
be frank you said that you've been
waiting 20 years to make this album why
I you know it's one of those things
where my mom and I watched all these old
movies when I was a kid that had all
these musical numbers in them and I'd
loved all these songs I've always loved
this era of music and then when I
started my career in 1991 country music
was my path and is my path but I've
always loved this music and I've
actually snuck a few of these songs into
my live shows over the years yeah and
I've always wanted make this record but
I always thought in my head well I can I
got to keep this other machine going I
can make that record I'll just I'll make
it next year I'll make it next year and
I was actually invited to sing at a
hundredth birthday celebration that the
Grammys did for Sinatra a few years ago
and it was a it was in memoriam and it
was really cool to be a part of that and
don was was the musical director and he
said I saying I'll be seeing you which
is on this record he say if you ever
thought about making a record these
songs I'm like I think about it all the
time and so that was kind of the
catalyst so let's do it listen let's
stop talking about it let's just get it
done and I've had a lot of fun on my
career making records and I've loved
every minute but I'm not sure I've ever
had more fun than I did with this
project because being here where iconic
Capitol Records yeah you know where
Frank recorded I used his microphone you
know they bring it like this is a stool
that Frank would sit on like why is this
not behind glass somewhere and getting
to work with incredibly talented
musicians some of which worked with
Sinatra it was just a dream come true so
much fun yeah and fans have been waiting
11 years for a full-length solo album
from you
and let's be frank is here so why did
you choose to make kind of like the
comeback with thanks to not show some
covers well I you know I've been on this
tour I've been on a three and a half
year tour with Garth and that was
everything and in between when we would
come home for a few days and and you
know he was like recharging I was
filming a cooking show so I was pretty
busy those three and a half years so
when that ended last December I was like
I
need to make new music and I wanted to
make the Sinatra record and I wanted to
make a regular studio country album so I
actually been working on both oh so
there's two projects and and that one
the the country record will come later
in the year but this is this was like
the the timing was right to do we we
were out here in June and July recording
this yeah and I felt like it would be a
great way to kind of around Valentine's
Day air or you know we're getting close
to Valentine's Day get this out now and
kind of just like hey we're back in
here's what we're doing and then then
we're gonna double whammy later in the
phone with another record do you get
nervous about what fans will think of
this project you get nervous just
releasing a new project I know it's been
a long time you do you try not to you
know but I mean that if you if you want
to call yourself an artist well you have
to make music because it's something
that moves you and then you hope that
somebody else enjoys that I learned a
long time ago you can't make a record
for someone else because you never know
what people are gonna like you know you
really if you but if if I'm having a
good time and I'm having strong emotions
and that comes across and the recording
and you hear that then hopefully you'll
be moved by that but if I'm singing a
song because I think well I think this
is a hit but I don't really love it but
I think it's gonna be really big hit I
think people can tell you know I think
that sincerity comes across or not so my
goal was just to immerse myself in this
and love it
and then hope that other people love it
too there is one original on this album
a song that you co-wrote with your
husband what's it like working with him
versus being married to him um sometimes
it's very similar I mean he's very I
will have to say he's very like open
he's very and and I think us being
together has helped us both be a little
bit more we used to both be like no this
is how we're doing it because we're both
bosses and we're both like independent
we're both like alphas you know so it's
like here's what we're doing and then
when you marry a guy like that then you
both have to compromise a little bit and
I think we both the songwriting thing
was great because he's very open and I
came to him with the title I said I'm
not I mean I he's in all the songwriting
Hall of Fame's I'm not um I've written a
few things but I'm not I wouldn't call I
don't call myself a songwriter and I
heard he's not a fan of the thing he
doesn't like it when I say that
but I had this title and I said I don't
know why I had this title in my head but
I do and he started singing this melody
that sounded like it was from another
era I really and we wrote this song over
the course a couple of weeks open to
suggestion I mean I'm telling this you
know 150 million selling record guy I
think you should try this lyric in this
spot but we collaborated it was great
and it ended up making this it this is I
guess this is where that that song
belonged but if you're gonna be in a if
you're gonna be a couple and especially
a couple who does the same thing you
know you learn how to that yin and yang
and that collaboration and when you know
it's it's a give-and-take and it's kind
of wonderful because it's like when I I
feel like I'm a strong independent woman
but I also don't have to be all the time
because he can be there when I need him
and vice versa you know sometimes I get
to be Wonder Woman you know so it's it's
a it's a great thing I love that he's
been hinting at a duets album yes what's
happening yeah we're gonna do it we we
we did a we dipped our toe in the water
with a Christmas duet album yes a couple
years ago and that was so much fun that
was and it's hard that the challenge is
we thought Christmas would be easier
because you can find songs that you know
that really just work it's it's hard to
find songs that we like to sing in the
same key if you listen to a lot of do it
as most people change the key because
because when women's ranges are usually
different so if we do change if we do
change keys we try to make it so subtle
that you go did they just do a key
change there because it didn't sound
like it we're very particular about that
and finding songs that we both are
really passionate about the thing we
experimented with on the Christmas album
that worked I think is that that we had
songs on that record that were not do it
yeah so there were maybe eight duets and
there were a couple of songs each that
it was that he did harm that he did
vocals that's just him and just me so I
think that'd be a cool way to do a duet
album though where you have songs that
are all the two of you and then songs
that maybe are you or it'd be easier to
find those songs that mix of songs but
yeah we're going to do it yeah